hi my name is Nick zisman and I'm part
of that and today we'll be talking about
using wolfram applications on your
mobile device it's a good afternoon
everybody
my name is Nick zisman and this is my
colleague parth pratap and we will be
talking today about the mobile apps that
we have on ios and android operating
systems for your phones and tablets and
we will also be learning about their use
cases in an educational setting Perth
will talk more about that so we're going
to start with Wolfram Alpha app it is
available for iOS and Android
now the way I like to describe Wolfram
Alpha is most search engines you type in
what you're looking for and it'll go out
to the web and it'll find some other
sites that may or may not have the
answer with Wolfram Alpha you and type
in your query and it will try to
actually produce an answer for you
without going anywhere else now we have
a mobile website for Wolfram Alpha but
we also have applications for iOS and
Android to have a somewhat better user
experience plus some exclusive features
that you can't get on the website on iOS
it will run on pretty much every iPhone
iPad and iPod touch made in the last
five years it requires a network
connection we sometimes get people
asking us for an offline version but if
they knew how much information was in
the Wolfram Alpha database they might
not really want that to happen it would
take a lot of space this is the the
currently shipping version that we have
is the last version that's going to
support 32-bit from the next release we
do onward it's going to require a 64-bit
iPhone I or iPad or iPod Touch which is
all currently shipping one's going back
about five or so years on Android we
require any Android phone running
Android KitKat or later and though it'll
run on a tablet or a Chromebook it is
not optimized for tablet screens and
again a network connection is required
so now I'm going to switch over to my
eye
had here and I'll show you what you can
do with the application all right I'm
going to launch it here and any query
that will work in the website will also
work in the application here so I'm
going to search for and I might work
better if I Orient yeah that's my
autocomplete bar that just popped up
here I'm going to touch that to complete
the query and it's going to run here
okay there we go and one of the things
one of the most popular use cases for
the Alpha apps actually is the step by
step solutions now we have two different
kinds of step by step solutions going
back a long ways we've had basic step by
step solutions which is you touch a
button and the application will give you
all of the solutions at once we just
shipped a new version of the Alpha app
last summer version 2.0 and this one has
a new feature which I'm going to show
you here where we touch step by step
solutions and it will give us the step
by step solutions step by step except
this time it didn't here oh that's
interesting
try a different one here
okay it was not doing this yesterday but
I'll go back here and when some of the
other things that you can do here once
we've got results as you know that's
really okay this query isn't working
that well let me try a different query
it was sorry about that it was not doing
that yesterday see ones base to that
should probably be better off okay we
got step by steps there
and it's giving me everything - okay I
don't know what's going on here
certainly wasn't doing that yesterday
but moving on here one of the other
features that we have here is the image
as input if you see the little camera
button there in the near the top right
corner I can touch the camera icon here
now this feature is actually pay wold
you can either be an alpha pro
subscriber or you can buy the one-time
in app purchase in order to unlock the
future you can take photos here using
either I can take one using the camera
or I can use an existing photo I'm going
to touch photo library to use an
existing photo and I'm going to use a
photo of a very cute cat here that's my
cat by the way and there are some things
we can do here like I'm going to type
monochrome and go and what it's going to
do here so it's going to take the image
that I sent the server here and it's
going to do something interesting here
in particular it's going to convert it
to monochrome there it is and some of
the things I can do with it here is if I
long touch on the picture here I can
share the picture here and I can say for
example airdrop and I can send it to my
laptop here or I could email it or save
it to Dropbox or do something where I
can with it there right ok it just got
sent to my computer laptop and so I'm
going to stop here and go back to my
laptop
okay and then I go back to my desktop
there and there it is so those are some
of the things that you can do with the
Alpha app and we've an on here the next
step I want to talk about is Wolfram
cloud this is also iOS and Android and
this will allow you to create and edit
your notebooks that are on the Wolfram
cloud website its requires also any
iPhone made in the last six years as
well as iPads and iPod touch you can use
it with an external keyboard if you've
got one it's not necessary it just
enhances the experience somewhat on
Android it also requires KitKat on both
iOS and Android the cloud app takes a
lot of memory so in general the more
physical memory that your device has the
more pleasant the experience you will
have you'll be able to open larger
notebooks with it and both network
connection is required you also need a
Wolfram ID those are free you do not
need a subscription to use the cloud app
and if your organization happens to have
a private cloud first of all thank you
and secondly in both the iOS and the
Android apps you can connects the cloud
app to your private cloud on iOS you do
it through the settings application on
Android there is a widget inside the app
of that it will allow you to change the
server and real quick here I'll switch
over to the cloud app okay Thank You
parth okay and then pretty much anything
that you can do on the desktop site I'll
rotate it here will also work inside the
apps so I can try something like type
here and then you'll notice there that's
the auto completion bar it's a little
bit different than it is on desktop it
appears right above the keyboard here I
can long press on one of these and I can
touch the button here that looks like a
dot dot dot to bring up
function templates I'll choose a
function template this is iOS only
currently I believe we're still working
on this on Android and then I'll try
something not terribly interesting but
to show you that it works it's to
negative 5 to 5 evaluate ok and one
other thing we can do here inside the
cloud app is you see this little button
here that looks like an image but in
again we can take photos with the camera
or a photo library I don't know what's
on this device no part ok sorry about
that but yes we can you can take photos
here and insert them into notebooks and
then you can also run different image
operations on them and they that's how
they work that way and I'll move on now
there are a few things that you can't
currently do in the cloud app like you
can't create new folders you can't move
objects between them or create or edit
scheduled tasks a few of these things
you can do inside the next application
that I'm going to talk about here and
one other thing
there are several privacy prompts inside
to the Alpha and the cloud apps and we
use like for example your location and
the Alpha app in order to do
location-aware queries like airplanes
overhead and the cloud app we also use
them to initialize the value of here in
the kernel and you do not have to
provide that information to us if you
don't feel comfortable with doing that I
just wanted to say that now moving on to
the player application the player
application allows you to do your
notebooks or CDF files both offline and
online system requirements are pretty
much the same as the cloud app but since
the player application which is
available for iOS only I should say I
think is it's quite a little bit larger
than the cloud application because it
comes with a full technology stack our
entire kernel the same one that we use
on the desktop applications as well as a
modified front-end for touch use called
NB Lite the player application works
completely offline even if you have
dynamic content you can pinch zoom in it
rotate 3d graphics and you can connect
to multiple we're from local cloud
accounts so if you have like two
accounts on our cloud you can use that
or if you have a private cloud that's
you can connect to multiple different
user accounts on a private cloud as well
you can import your notebooks from
third-party clouds and transfer files
between Wolfram cloud and the local
device and even if you have multiple
accounts you can transfer files between
your multiple accounts in the background
and also if you have an iPad air 2 or
later you can use slide over and split
view the one downside to the warm player
app is you cannot edit or evaluate
any-anything in the app and although it
comes with a full colonel the one thing
that it lacks is j-link because we do
not have java on iOS and so anything
that depends on j-link will just fall
over and fail i don't know everything
off the top of my head but i know that a
number of importers and exporters depend
on je link and some things in the
interpreter and some other things but
most things work and also other cloud
deployments like forms and such won't
work in the player app and I can give a
quick demo here and then I should turn
over
all right player app is running I'm
going to actually air drops file I found
over to the iPad here I'm Stephen tried
to show this during the keynote
yesterday and it didn't work out very
well I'm using airdrop here and you can
see here that it came over and I can
interact with it this is the you see
down there at the bottom there is what
we show for dynamic content and you can
see here it works pretty well and also
you can go to your cloud and you can get
your files that way and I think that's
everything that I wanted to cover in
here so parth you can take it from here
Thank You Nick and thanks for not
exposing my password because the
screenshots had my new passwords on them
so now Nick has given an excellent
introduction to what our mobile apps are
so the next thing I want to talk about
is like how to actually use them for
your learning process and in an
education setting to talk about that I
really want to talk about how I see
their learning process to me learning is
about three different steps but they're
continuously happening it's discovery
creating and playing with what you just
created and that's why our three apps
are perfectly fitting one of the goals
so you can go through them try different
things because learning is all about
actually experiencing and getting your
hands dirty because unless you do it
you're gonna be like oh it's out here I
don't know what it is so you actually
have to try it out so to do that I went
to my old calculus book and I got an
example that actually gave me problem in
college so I will go over that I did
usable from alpha to do this problem and
homework back in the day so it was
understanding limits so when I started
learning calculus I had a bit of trouble
understanding limits so I was like okay
so how do I use the power goal from
language now to better understand limits
so here's the problem exactly as it
appeared in the textbook is
understanding the limit of that function
from left side right and at zero so
let's take a look
mr. Trevor
[Music]
perfect so we'll explore this question
the question of limits from all of our
different apps so let's start with the
Wolfram Alpha app oh look somebody
already typed the example in what a
coincidence so we will reevaluate the
example and if you recall the question
was understanding the limit at 0 and
from negative infinity and positive
infinity so I'm just gonna do the limit
of that question and not give it any
bounce for right now it's a hard problem
it's taking a while perfect so we see
the limit as if you're approaching from
negative 1 negative infinity and
infinity but we don't really care about
that we wanted it at zero so the limit
if you look at the plot by looking at it
you're like yeah the limit won't really
exist at zero because it's different if
your ticks approach it from left or
right but if you were to just do this
problem out for your textbook you would
have to calculate it so it would take
time
so what Wolfram Alpha does it lets you
visualize it really quickly so you can
be like okay so whatever a solution I
calculated by hand I can see okay it
makes sense if it converges to zero
you're like yeah I screwed up the
calculation somewhere so the limit is
different from left hand side which is
negative one and from the right hand
side it's one so there is no limit at
zero so that's what Wolfram Alpha really
allows you to do is drill down quickly
to a problem now let's say if you wanted
to investigate more limits but you had a
harder function like for example a
piecewise function which I never
understood till this day and I'm a math
major just so you know so we'll take a
look at Wolfram cloud so which is the
power of like using the Wolfram language
and actually digging into a problem so
let's take a look at it
oh wow somebody actually typed that one
up - what a day so we'll start by
defining the function and plotting it so
that's the piecewise function as you can
see it has different pieces now the next
thing you can do is just do a numerical
table of trying to get the values before
you do any calculation and see ok what
do you think the limit is gonna approach
so let's try it when X is equal to 1 so
now we have the left hand side table and
the right hand side table and you can
see they're both getting towards 3 so
this way you can see the step as you for
increasing X and what the results would
be not to do this out by hand would take
a long time and this lets you quickly
calculate it all out and continue using
the power of Wolfram language you can
calculate the limit set 1 4 & 6 so those
are the values but at 6 it's a bit weird
because there is no limit at 6 so you're
like okay so what's going on there so
you can go further down and then you can
do directional limits at that point and
then you're like ah it's different so
they don't really exist for that
function at that point so that's using
Wolfram cloud so you can dig into the
problem now now let's say you don't want
to do any of this and you just want to
learn about the limits you can use the
player app and you can grab
demonstrations from the demonstrations
website which has a lot of examples I
believe 12,000 plus examples of
different demonstrations so you can
learn about different concepts so I just
shows one called limit laws and this one
teaches you about the different laws for
limits so if you were to tap on the
graphic it would pull up the different
functions you can try and the different
combinations so let's say we switch our
functions and you wanted to learn about
the some law so you can be like oh ok so
here are the two functions which are in
the dashed line and if you combine them
what would be the final function which
is in green oh and how does it behave in
your around one so in this one you don't
have to do anything you can grab the app
this demonstration is online study the
different laws of limits and be like ok
I understood this much better I'm a
visual learner so I understand things a
lot better by just looking at them
rather than like writing it out so this
is
perfect so those were the quick
introduction to the three apps and
education let me switch back to Nick is
gonna interest password thank you so as
we went through if you have a problem
and you define it you can use all of our
apps you understand different pieces of
it and then put them together so for
students that's really helpful because
somebody might learn one way somebody
might learn some other way but if you
were to put them all together they might
have a very good understanding of limits
I finally understand limits after
preparing for this talk so we're good
there and later I have published this
notebook so you can try it out and then
the limit laws demonstration is already
online so you can grab that too so
putting it all together we have a
complete suite of apps that you can use
to really enhance your learning and the
one of the big goals is we want to make
it accessible to everyone
so you can get started for pretty much
free and we really believe if students
have the tools to use them they will use
and if it really enhance your learning
so that's why we're trying to make it
accessible to everyone a quick review so
with Wolfram Alpha you can ask all kinds
of questions and here's an example of
all the different question examples we
have you can use these two for different
categories and learn about those and
really expand your car city and just try
different things out because I was
student the more you learn the better
and will from cloud you can use well
from language to really like dig down in
a problem and actually create something
new because we have so many functions
and they're so well documented you can
use those in player app you don't have
to do anything just you can grab
somebody else what they made and try it
out and it works great for that and this
brings me back to the learning process
how it's a three-step process but you
can use different apps for every step of
it and learn through that and we have
some additional resources such as the
Wolfram demonstration project which I
already mentioned so there's tons of
demonstrations you can use to
learn from there and then we have
courses on goal from you you can use
those in these three apps to go through
those courses and our excellent
documentation here are some of the other
notable talks which will be helpful and
some of them are in this room so that
will make it really easy you don't even
have to go anywhere such as yawns talk
next and we have a couple of meetups at
the Homewood Suites and we would really
like you to come and bring any feedback
any questions or if you have anything to
say about us we have one for notebook
and one for mobile devices so we really
appreciate that
and if you want to just send us your
feedback through email later on here are
a couple emails you can send it to us so
and if you want to grab the apps here
the QR codes or phones to the screen
here this is for the Wolfram Alpha app
for iOS okay we can move on to the next
one Iowa app for Android finally there's
player for iOS this is a little bit
larger download than the others and
that's all we have thank you so much
[Applause]